Cyril Eldin quand les Balkany seront à
la retraite vous considérez vraiment
comme au chômage technique
et maintenant voici mon stagiaire Tom
villa
[Applaudissements]
le métier commence à rentrer tu auras
ton CDD ça me fait plaisir je vous ai
mis un petit spéculoos j'espère un CDI
comment ça va
je vous avais pas dit Thierry je suis un
petit peu de de mentalisme de magie j'ai
fait une prédiction vous verrez à la fin
de la chronique on va voir ce qui se
passe dit avant is bonsoir
brunes à la peau claire aux lèvres
flamboyantes et à la poitrine généreuse
si elle était française c'était Roselyne
Bachelot mais on a de la chance c'est
dit
vous revenez au Crazy Horse jusqu'au 30
mars merci du fond du cœur parce que ça
nous évite le retour d'Arielle Dombasle
non c'est vrai
Marilyn Manson mais sans les couilles
non ok François vous l'avez toujours le
fauteuil que vous aviez dans intouchable
ou pas
à mon avis c'est le meilleur moyen
je peux me permettre on peut faire un
petit selfie
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
mais non mais c'est très gentil parce
que j'ai vu au crédit s'il y a le pack
VIP à 2000 euros on peut voir le
spectacle après la rencontrer dans les
coulisses et faire une photo donc vous
m'avez économisé 2000 balles merci du
fond du cœur
[Applaudissements]
vraiment je suis fan de vous que j'ai
pas de vanne mais c'est sincère je suis
pas
un médecin de campagne un petit peu la
suite de Dr Quinn fan médecin mais sauf
qu'à la fin vous mariez pas avec un
indien non mais c'est fou ce thème de la
désertification médicale parce que en
même temps c'est vrai que après avoir vu
la soupe aux choux tu te dis pas
spontanément tiens je viens de faire 10
ans d'études je vais aller à la campagne
soigner des mecs qui passent leur temps
à lâcher des caisses et à se bourrer la
gueule
Cyril Eldin quand j'ai dit à ma mère ce
soir on reçoit Cyril Eldin m'a dit qui
ça et
non je lui dis maman Cyril Eldin le mec
il va faire chier les politiques à
l'Assemblée nationale elle m'a fait ah
oui alors Cyril vous êtes la bête noire
des hommes politiques vous les cherchez
vous les titiller vous êtes un peu le
petit frère relou de Jean-Michel Apathie
Thierry je vous avais dit quoi je fais
de la magie prédiction regardez
tu vas trop fort
[Applaudissements]
de l'improvisation vous avez parce que
c'est ça qui est fou c'est que Cyril il
prépare rien il y va et voilà on verra
ce qui se passe c'est un peu comme le
mandat de François Hollande c'est un peu
pareil c'est lui qui m'inspire alors
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Cyril Eldin quand les Balkany seront à
la retraite vous considérez vraiment
comme au chômage technique
je pourrais plus partir en vacances chez
eux donc
dites Avantis Dita sur scène vous prenez
votre bain dans une coupe de champagne
géante ça vous fait quoi d'avoir réalisé
le fantasme de Gérard Depardieu
François Cluzet François j'ai lu que
vous refusiez souvent de refaire une
seconde fois ce que vous aviez déjà vécu
dans votre métier ça va votre vie
sexuelle sinon ou pas
Thierry Givet bonne émission et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu